McDavid check it in and out on Peters
gets around into let's go on the
forehead transits nothing in Fallon the
2015 NHL draft will be the legendary I'm
David Senate radical Center Newmarket
Ontario North Chelmsford Massachusetts
it's been ten years since the Sidney
Crosby draft Pittsburgh Penguins select
Sidney Crosby Connor McDavid has the
chance to be that next NHL field
Jeff T always looking for the past great
puck stealing ability watch Connor
McDavid on the wraparound how far out he
come McDavid as the inside track but now
Jack Eichel has the chance to change the
face of American hockey
Jack Eichel is the best american
prospect since Patrick Kane first two
strikes are as explosive as you're going
to see they power forward I like to play
with the buck on my stick it's such a
slashing type skater and the power that
he generates in its lower body is really
tough to contain it's a lot of hard work
and sacrifice and focus everyone's
working hard early now it's who's
working harder I've always wanted it
when I get the pop I'm looking to attack
I'm looking to go to net because that's
my first instinct I want to be an impact
player whatever it takes I want to be
the next best American hockey player one
year away it's all about 2015 the United
States Canada first place apart and be
rising hockey power
99.7 explained 653 game was Cherokee the
top US scorer at the u18 world
championship MVP I'm working to be the
next big thing